the Joe Rogan experience and this goes
back to the thing about Trump where I
told you on CNN all they did for an hour
in a [ __ ] half was talking about
Russia and it's like I'm sitting there
going I just covered a story on my show
last week about how the head of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau is
a guy named Mick Mulvaney he took over
fifty thousand dollars from the
predatory payday loan industry Donald
Trump at his inauguration took over a
million dollars from the predatory
payday loan industry they just scrapped
the rules that were supposed to clean up
that industry and now they're letting
them charge nine hundred and fifty
percent Interest you want the [ __ ]
conspiracy there it is right there
and you're not talking about it uh
Boonton if you're Russia he's a [ __ ]
Manchurian Candidate loud noises and he
curses a lot and [ __ ] stormy Daniels
I don't give a [ __ ] about any of that
talk about the [ __ ] that mattered I care
about stormy no I do wonder what's gonna
happen with the indictments I do wonder
so those people are pleading guilty now
and you know the concern is that it's
gonna trickle so here's the thing here's
the thing is Donald Trump a corrupt
businessman [ __ ] yes anybody who says
he's not has no [ __ ] idea what this
guy's been into there's evidence he did
deals with the Mafia he has a hotel in
Panama which was laundering drug money
so do I think he's a criminal
yes do I think he did money laundering
yes would it be good if Muller somehow
got him on these things of course it
would be but the idea that he's a
Manchurian Candidate or he did treason
is so ridiculous that it makes me a guy
who's massively anti Trump scoff and get
really angry when people try to push
that narrative and here's the thing
there's it's an open legal question as
to whether or not you can indict a
sitting president usually what has to
happen is you have to impeach a sitting
president well right now Congress is
overwhelmingly Republican you know who's
not gonna [ __ ] impeach Donald Trump
even if they prove the worst case
scenario that he's some sort of
Manchurian Candidate the Republicans are
not gonna [ __ ] impeach him so at the
end of the day when the Democrats focus
on this ad nauseam the reason they're
doing that is because it's something
that they feel comfortable and safe
talking about because they don't have to
talk about medicare-for-all
or free college or a living wage or
getting the corporate
politics or ending the [ __ ] wars
which they also support so they're not
talking about real issues and they're
focusing on this the fake scandal and
sensationalism because they think it'll
score them cheap points with the
electorate and it won't and they think
there's an end game here and there's not
but there is something there right I
mean if yes people are worried but if
people are getting indicted I'm sure
with Russia thing so I'll break that
down Paul Manafort is one of the people
who got indicted right SuperDuper
corrupt laundering money Michael Flynn
st. saving money how so so in the case I
know more of the details about Flynn so
Flynn is a guy he got what's-his-face
Muller went after Flynn and it was
proven that Flynn took five hundred
thousand dollars from the Turkish
government and in return for that he
pushed the Trump administration to not
arm the Kurds who are fighting Isis and
the reason why is because Turkey hates
the Kurds and they don't want us to arm
the Kurds so in other words Michael
Flynn was doing the bidding of the
Turkish government and pushing their
influence in our government and he
didn't register as a foreign agent in
the process so exactly so he's doing the
bidding of the Turkish government and
not disclosing that and you have to
register as a foreign agent if you're
gonna take that money and you're gonna
do that and this doesn't run down the
Trump well that's the open question as
to whether or not at some point along
the way whether it's with Russia or with
other countries by the way nobody talks
about the fact that Trump registered
eight new businesses in Saudi Arabia
when he was on the campaign trail and
then he just gave them over a hundred
billion dollar weapons deal
he also took two hundred and seventy
thousand dollars from top Saudi
officials at his hotel when he was
president elect and then again he gave
him over a hundred billion dollar
weapons deal the case of Israel Jared
Kushner has you know millions of dollars
from Israeli banks and then lo and
behold when Donald Trump was
president-elect they tried to push the
UN to not condemn Israel over their
illegal settlements so you have his
entire administration is just a grab bag
of corruption and foreign influence say
but it's far influence across the board
and its influence also from corporations
but again people are not focusing on the
corporations and they're not focusing on
the other countries that they're corrupt
with because they're a hyper focusing on
the Russia thing and at the end of the
day they want to impeach Trump over
Russia but like I said it's gonna be
hard to prove and then it's
open question if you can indict I don't
think you can indict a sitting president
you have to impeach they're not gonna
[ __ ] impeach so really this is
Democrats sniffing their own farts and
acting like they're doing something
important when they're really not
and the only there-there in my opinion
is money laundering he's a corrupt
businessman but he's not some sort of
Putin puppet because he's actually done
many policies there against Putin so for
example he armed Ukrainian rebels who
are fighting Russia right now you don't
arm people who are fighting Russia if
you're their [ __ ] puppet you know he
also is bombing Syria and we're staying
indefinitely in Syria they just
announced that recently you don't that
Syria the Syrian government that's one
of Putin's top allies you're not gonna
permanently occupy their country and try
to fight that government if you're in
bed they're doing a NATO buildup on
Russia's border right now so if you're
if you're at Putin's puppet you don't
have a military buildup on his border
there was just a story the other day
about how now the u.s. our military
sending our ships to the Black Sea
right on Russia's [ __ ] border so it's
military escalation and that's another
part of this that pisses me off is that
if the Democrats really wanted to resist
Trump resist that say I don't want to
send our [ __ ] military to get into a
standoff with Russia I don't want to
bomb [ __ ] Syria and permanently
occupy it this is how the Democrats
should be resisting they should be
resisting Trump from a left-wing
position from an anti interventionist
position but instead everything you hear
from the Democrats is he's under Putin's
thumb and he needs to make sure that
he's even harder on Putin and he does
more sanctions against Putin and he
escalates further with Russia listen man
they're a nuclear-armed power do you
want to [ __ ] get into a confrontation
with the nuclear-armed power we're
sitting here living our lives just going
about our business and we're this is I
mean this is crazy we're rolling the
dice and we're playing a game of chicken
with Vladimir Putin do you think that
they're just caught up in this sexy
thing yes a lot of it is sensationalism
why it's also what the public is really
focused on right now so I think that
gathers ratings I think they're driving
it mmm I think it's driven from the top
down from the establish from the media
down from the Democrats down because
again if you talk to regular people
they're [ __ ] hurting right wages have
been stagnant since 1980 there's 30
million people that don't have health
care in Trump's first year in office
three million more people lost health
care because he did all these executive
orders that basically
took a hatchet to Obamacare so you have
all these people who are really hurting
there they care about their wages they
care about you know not being saddled
with over a trillion dollars in student
loan debt this is the [ __ ] regular
people care about so if when they turn
on CNN and they see Russia Russia Russia
even if you don't like Trump I despise
Trump with every fiber of my [ __ ]
being but when I see this I roll my
[ __ ] eyes and then they have the
nerve to say Oh Trump won't shut up
about Russia you were talking about her
all day and he responded to it and
because he responds it to it you're like
oh there he goes again with Russia yeah
it's it's gonna be interesting to see
how this all plays out I'm really
fascinated and I'm fasting to see if he
can make it out of for years well not
only well I think he's gonna do you
thing he's gonna run maybe he's gonna
run again and he's gonna win again he
has a chance he does has a [ __ ]
chance because if the Democrats run
Kamala Harris if they run Cory Booker or
any of the other corporatists he can win
because he's gonna go right back into
his tap-dance about being a populist and
helping people and guess what in the
first few years of his tax bill regular
people did get a tax cut so he's gonna
say looking look at your tax bill I just
gave you no extra thousand dollars this
year who you want to vote for and so
there is an argument that he's gonna
make to the people and if you don't have
somebody like Bernie Sanders or Bernie
Sanders talking about the issues that
matter to people well then of course he
can [ __ ] win again listen there there
was I was laughed at when I said if it's
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton he can
win people laughed at me
you
[Applause]